fine in that case welcome everyone to
today's meeting of the panel
if you have any technical difficulties
during the meeting then please contact
the democratic services officer on call
who will attempt to assist you today's
office for on call is james clapson and
the number to call is 577
200. i'll ask participants
when you're not speaking please mute
your microphone
microphones must only be on if the
participant has been granted
permission to speak and to gain my
permission to speak please indicate on
the chat
and i will then make a note and call you
when it is your turn
would everyone present please ensure
that their mobile phones are turned to
silent
that they are not used to make or
receive phone calls whilst the meeting
is in progress
please also refrain from checking your
emails and ensure that you're in a quiet
room for the duration of the meeting
please note that this meeting is being
live streamed for members of the public
the meeting will also be recorded and
will be subsequently broadcast on the
internet
can i ask that members of the panel
confirm that they are present in the
meeting when i call out your name
councillor curry
here chair councillor curry is
substituting for councillor campbell
um i spoke to councillor campbell at the
weekend
and i'm sorry to tell members he's very
very unwell at the moment
so i'm sure you'll join with me in
sending our best wishes to him
uh councillor boyd
president councillor coleman cook
president chair councillor hopkinson
yeah i'm here chair thank you councillor
huxley
i think i'm representing councillor
huxley a chair good evening councilor
okay thank you all right uh councillor
keane
[Music]
councillor kane no
okay uh councillor pat moore here chair
uh councillor paul moore here chad
councillor linda piper
council linda piper
no councillor ratigan
[Music]
i can see you councillor i can't hear
you but we know you're here
um councillor piper you've just joined
us yes
having problems with my internet as well
okay
okay all right fine gotcha um counselor
rather gun
no uh councillor rozeki here chair
and councillor scott here chair
lovely um speaking under 20.1
i've not received any requests to speak
under 20.1
are there any members present who wish
to speak under 20.1
now i can't see anyone indicating i've
not received any request
for public speaking so moving on to the
substantive part of the agenda gender
item number one
apologies for absence uh apologies were
received by councillor
from council campbell substituted by
councillor curry
and uh councillor arrow you are
substituting for councillor huxley
okay thank you that's right that's right
yes okay fine uh
agenda item two any declarations of
interest
i can't see anybody indicating
agenda item three minutes to the
previous meeting
to approve the meeting of the minute
sorry of the ovian scrutiny panel
meeting held on the 24th of november
2020
a copy of which was attached to the
agenda pack could i have a proposal for
those minutes please
i'd like to propose that chair for more
thank you councillor moore
and the seconder i'll second that chair
councillor common cook
thank you councillor coleman cook
members we've got a proposal a second uh
they agreed i can't see any objections i
see lots of people nodding so i'll take
those as approved thank you very much
agenda item for the 2021-22 budget
i will now call upon tim willis to
introduce the report
thank you chair um as councillor yates
said to cabinet this budget has been set
within the context of significant change
for local government
and for local government finance kovid
19 has forced us to focus on the very
short term
and has been a drain on reserves as well
as a drain
on council finance and council staff
reserves
in some ways this is a coveted free
budget
the budget gap is almost all due to
domestic issues such as pay and
contractual inflation and increased
waste disposal costs
and there were some projected reductions
in government grants also
but nothing that was specifically
covered related this is because we've
treated kovid as essentially having a
one-off impact
albeit one-off in 2021 and 21-22 as well
as in 2021
members will recall that visa charges
have already passed through this panel
and been approved by a council
i'd also remind members that any budget
recommendations from osp
that have cost or reduced income should
have a funding source
osp can make such recommendations to
cabinet
but i would be advising cabinet a
section 151 officer
that they should not be accepted unless
a funding source is identified
for referral onto council i'd also
repeat what councillor yates said in his
introduction and cabinet
that in paragraph 13.6.1 the increase in
average rent between this year and next
year is 1 pounds 98
not 1 pounds 89 as the report states
i'm happy to answer any questions from
members
okay yeah thank you mr willis um
yeah i mean i think the points well made
about any recommendations that come from
here we've got to say
where alternative funding would come
from i think also it's fair to say that
um as usual you've been assiduous in
trying to keep members
informed all the way through the budget
making process
and i know you've held various workshops
we've got briefings and so on
so hopefully members tonight won't have
too many surprises to throw your way but
members do you have any questions of mr
willis or any comments to make
um sorry cancer
zeki sorry for i i've had difficulty
getting the
the chat up so councillor that's all
right chair i've difficulty myself with
it
uh just a quick comment again um
uh mr willis and his team have done a
sterling job in these trying times and
i'd like to pass on our thanks for
all the sterling work that his team have
done thank you
thank you uh casper is i'm sure that's
echoed by everybody i'm sure
the conservative group would feel
exactly the same way
council linda piper
thank you chair i'd just like to pass on
my thanks to
mr willis and his team a bit like
councillor roses
rooseve has just done it was interesting
um item four where it says resident
views and corporate priorities
um that there was only 57
of the of who was asked were surprised
that the council
received such a small proportion of
their council tax
um and that information perhaps should
be
uh more available to the people of fanec
who think that they pay too much council
tax
thank you okay
thank you council piper anyone else have
any comments
um i've got just a couple of queries
really um the first is
uh at 13.7
um to do with the hra
talk about adjustments made between
accounting basis and funding basis
and it's nearly half a million pounds
could you explain what that is
mr willis please
um thank you chair let me just find the
uh
it's 13.7
okay so it's in the table um
and it's right up to near the bottom the
479 000.
that's it yeah yeah um
yes this is required in order to show
the complete picture within the hra
um that is true of the general fund as
well but it's normally invisible
when it comes to the general fund but we
have to show the complete picture in the
hra
it's to reflect things about different
valuations of assets within the housing
revenue account
and that depending on the funding basis
of those assets
we have to reflect the different numbers
which is the
adjusting figure of 479 000
it doesn't have a material impact on the
overall bottom line as to what rent
what needs to be covered from rents rent
income
but we have to include it um i believe
this question has been asked in previous
years
and uh i might have asked it so i should
probably have a more comprehensive
um explanation to hand but i'm happy to
provide a more comprehensive explanation
as to the
specific accounting treatment and the
breakdown of the 479 000 if that would
help you
okay i mean i would be interested i'm
not sure if other members would
but i would be interested in seeing that
but i was more interested in finding out
it didn't have any material impact um
i've got another question
11.7 talking about the hra
major repairs reserve
table there would indicate that the
reserves stood
at 15.5 million on the 31st of march
2020
and their plans to reduce to 384
000 by the 31st of march 2022 so
the question there is is that reduction
and the small amount that's left
prudent but following on from that
um the table i've referred to there
indicates a movement in 2122
of 7.676 million
but at annex 3 it suggests that 11.986
million is being used from master
repairs reserve so could you clarify
those two
points for me please
okay um the first point yes um we're
using the major repairs reserves
substantially
over this year and next year i'd say
that this year it also reflects
the planned capital program so the
reality is likely to be because the
level of slippage that
a lot more will fall into 2122 it will
chase the
spending um but the the reality is
we are using a substantial amount of
that reserve
in order to fund the significant
investment plan that we have
for the housing revenue account stock in
in particular the tower blocks
um it is a low level that's left at 384.
um in fact overall the level of reserves
in the hra is reducing substantially
um if you look at that table and we know
that and we know that
for the next few years the hoa will be
running at a deficit
as well but both the major repairs
reserve
and the overall level of reserves within
the hra
won't go below prudent levels before
they are projected to start
the hra moves back into surplus and
that's so that we can start replenishing
those reserves but
there's it's it's a worthwhile point to
make that
um we i will regularly informed members
that general fund reserves
were low before kovid and they've only
got lower well
um that's because in the past the hra
has been a in a healthier position
but with a combination of bringing east
kent housing in-house
the discovery of a number of aspects of
the single system
um and uh and the condition of the stock
has led us to require a significant
input of reserves of resources into
the hra and that's a consequence of that
um
on the the second point of this the
apparent discrepancy between
the figure in in the for 21 22 in that
table seven
and annex three did you say
an x3 yeah which is the hoa capital
program
yeah so i'm guessing at the bottom it's
got a funding breakdown of
that's it yeah yeah and for 21.22 it
says 11.96
986. special i don't know is the answer
okay um it's all right it's only the odd
four million different so
i quickly not too bothered i could have
a guess
that that program incorporates
some slippage from 2021 right and so
it's inflated by that the overall
capital program spend is inflated by the
fact of inclusion of the slippage from
2021
and so the use that's a bit referring to
the point i made at the beginning
that the major repairs reserve which
follows the spending
has been brought into that figure in the
in the annex
that reflects to 2021 but that might not
be accurate because i don't have the
breakdown of that 11.9 million
before me but i can provide that
subsequent to this meeting
yeah again i'd be interested in i think
thank you mr willis thank you very much
my final point is that the report
actually states that the 151 officer
your good self
um had an optimistic view
and a pessimistic view of how covid
might impact
uh and then it goes on to say that
you've taken
the middle ground so two points really
the first is
you know your level of confidence in
making that decision
but do you have any idea what the budget
would have looked like had you taken the
pessimistic view
i think pessimistic view um
would have been that as as the report
says in in paragraph 2.4
even though we know there's now um a
vaccine
it turns out that that vaccine take up
is slow
and maybe a lot of people decide not to
take it up so that doesn't diminish the
level of infections and it
means that there's further local
outbreaks
but also the the wider macroeconomic
impact of covid is really significant so
it has a big impact on unemployment
and business failures within fanet that
would have a consequential impact on our
business rates
it would increase our council tax
support payments and reduce the amount
of income we generate from business
rates council tax
and fees and charges the other
pessimistic view would be that
there isn't an increase in visitor
numbers in fact visitor numbers
are just as low as they were in 2020
um going into our our sort of summer
season in 21 22.
if all of those things came to came into
play
whilst i would expect there to be more
government funding to support that
impact of kovid than they've already
announced
um that that might not happen so the
pessimistic viewers know what they're
going to pay us
that's all they're going to pay us that
they've promised us and nothing more
if all of those things came to pass what
i would have to fall back on
is the the reserves that we'll be
carrying into 2122 from 2021
because the council made a decision to
identify three million pounds worth of
earmarks
our own earmarked reserves to plug the
covered gap in 20
20 21 this year and it turns out that we
don't need to use all of those
reserves that we thought we had to this
year we'll be able to call upon that
next year as a bank
um and only then would we start eating
into
what was the very low level of reserves
that we had in even before covid
if if that happened as well then we
would be having to have an emergency
budget
and we'd have to be finding additional
savings on at least a one-off basis
in year in 2122
before we resorted to anything worse
than that
so that's the pessimistic view the
reason why
i'm not as pessimistic as that although
i don't want to be accused of being an
optimist
never let it be said mr willis it's is
that um
the reality is the vaccine is rolling
out and we've had some promises
on from the government about the speed
with which that will be rolled out
um i think we we generally feel that the
level of
new infections is falling in both infant
and in the country
at large even though we're we're still
in the probably the worst moment
in terms of the number of
hospitalizations and deaths
um and so many of us would have been
affected by by people
um who have been um unfortunate enough
to contract
the kovit 19. i i think that we
from this point onwards things should
begin to ease
and i think that's generally the
perception that we're receiving from
government who are in the best position
to
to know so i think things are going to
improve slowly during
21 22 and remember that doesn't start
until april and even by april we would
hope
that things have improved a bit um
the other thing i think and this is
tentative
i think that we've been less affected by
covid than quite a few other places
around the country and around kent
that's partly been because
of our relative resilience of our
underlying financial position
and i don't mean by that we our reserves
level because we had low reserves anyway
but what i would say is that we don't
have
the the sort of characteristics that um
local authorities that have been really
hit by kobe have had have been things
like
town center car parks where they're
really dependent upon income from town
centre car parks
and we don't have a huge town center car
park
income generation we obviously have town
centres
and we obviously have car parks but our
level of income hasn't been affected by
anything like the magnitude of some
other
local authorities not too far from fanat
and the other thing is we chose not to
invest
in commercial ventures um
we chose that um and and i would say
sort of
uh modestly on behalf of the council
that we did that because we didn't have
the option to do it anyway we didn't
have the risk appetite to do it and we
didn't have the money to do it
but i like to tell people that fanet
chose that because it was a wise
decision to do that
i thought it would be funny to to to go
down that route and
now kogi has proven that to be the case
where a lot of local authorities have
taken a hammering on their commercial
rent
income assumptions and they get no
government support
for that income loss um so i think
looking forward i think we we can be
comforted by that fact that even if kofi
continues to affect us longer than we
thought then we won't be here
in those ways but also um
the very thing that sometimes holds us
back the seasonality of our income
um not just fees and charges but more
generally the the impact it has on
businesses and the ability for our local
businesses to thrive and to create
employment
um the thing that that holds us back
sometimes the seasonality but
i'm hopeful that next summer we will see
a big
uptick in in visitors assuming the
vaccine rolls out and assuming that
travel restrictions are more relaxed
they're going to relax first on domestic
travel and if people
have less money to spend and they're
looking for somewhere to go
i'm hopeful that our economy will will
benefit from
a significant uptick in staycations now
when i'm not i'm not building a budget
on that assumption
but i think that that is a reasonable
assumption to make if you're thinking of
the optimistic scenario
sure yeah thank you mr willis i think
yeah but very true and
i think your points are well made about
neighbouring authorities and decisions
they may have made
and they don't need to know why we made
ours do they so that's okay
we just claimed we were clairvoyant and
leave it at that so thank you for that
um councillor boyd you you've got a
question or a comment to make
thank you chair um yeah it just seems
more of a trivial question really uh in
relation i think all the big questions
have been done
um but on uh paragraph 15 table
nine i was curious as to why the one
bedroom house social rents
average is higher than the affordable
event
comparing the trends for the other
accommodations i just wondered why it
was a bit of a peculiar one
compared to the others okay
can can anybody answer that question
um i know bob porter's on the call so i
don't know if he's having
oh yeah throwing the hospital past mr
wheeler
which paragraph are we um let me just
talk for a moment bob and it might help
you yes
so it's it's table nine in in paragraph
15
of the report and it shows that the
affordable rents as you'd expect would
be
higher than social wins in every
instance
and it appears and this this could be
an error um this it appears that a
one-bedroom
house and i don't even know if we have
any one-bedroom houses but
a one-bedroom house affordable and is
lower
than the social rent figure as
councillor boyd has pointed out which
does seem rather odd
it does and fred i don't know the answer
to that either um
yeah my my first question would be do we
have that one bedroom house anywhere i
suspect that possibly we don't but
i i'm happy to go away and have a look
at that and clarify that for you
councillor boyd
um does seem anomaly because generally
as affordable rents are higher than
uh social rents and
i'll take that up and get back to
councillor boyd because it's my
responsibility i just thought you might
know
i wasn't trying yeah no sorry i don't
know
top top marks counselor boyd for
stumping the experts hold on
okay um members i can't see anybody else
oh sorry
uh cass hopkinson you like to ask a
question sorry
thanks chair yeah just a couple of uh
related questions um
i'm sure this information is available
to us somewhere but i just want because
we've mentioned a few times
that the reserves are low i just
wondered if you can remind us of the
figure of that i've got
in my memory vaguely the figure about 20
million but i wonder if you can
remind us of what that is and also
related to that
uh you mentioned the three million that
was earmarked from the reserves but we
didn't need spend at the end
i'm sure this has been considered
already but i just wonder if uh
what the views are on you know because
we are proposing to increase rents
um what what views there are on on using
that three million not to increase rents
i'm not sure what the saving is
um the total saving is from from that
increase i know it's only a small one
i wondered if i could just get the
response on that
yes mr um
first of all the reserves are set out in
table seven
in paragraph 11.7 um
both the general fund and the housing
revenue account reserves
and they show a use of reserves
um during the the two years both on the
general fund and housing revenue account
um what i'd point out there is that the
movement in 2021
as it as i alluded to the use of general
fund reserves is 1.7 million
not 3 million and that's because back in
september we thought we would be 3
million but then we got more government
funding than we thought
and now cost the cost of covid fell a
little bit
so that meant that we will only need to
draw upon 1.7 million
the working assumption in this report
and in the budget monitoring report
which was also on the cabinet agenda
is that we know that we've recognized
that and we will need to make a decision
about what to do
about that but not now we wait to see
how covey plays out
and what the provisional outcome
position looks like in this financial
year
and that's reasonably a reasonably
prudent approach which i entirely
support
what it means is that some of those
decisions
um that when we went through the when
council went through the
the reserves list of and come up with
three million pounds worth
um what it would mean would be we didn't
make we reversed out of some of those
decisions which would be the working
assumption
so where we said we'd make a saving on
on one particular emr reserve
in order to fund the three million we
could say well we won't do that after
all
so it's not creating more money
necessarily it might just be reversing
some decisions that we made
but of course that's up to council it
will be up to council to make that
decision at the time
my my assumption that i've advised in
this report
is that they is that we hold those
reserves because of the level of
uncertainty and because of the level of
underlying reserves anyway
we hold those reserves this protection
against
things going bad that we can't currently
anticipate
but that that is still recognized it's
still there in a covered shortfall
reserve
and everybody can see it and then we'll
make a conscious decision about what to
do about that
in the next few months um as regards the
point about
rents well the the three million use of
reserves is general fund reserves not
the housing revenue account reserves
and rents are within the housing revenue
account
and as you can see in the hoa reserves
they've gone down significantly from
from the three reserves there you can
see at the start of this financial year
which amount to about 25 million um
they're down to about less than four
million at the end of next year
forecast so there isn't any headroom in
any case to
consider and in fact when i've advised
this
panel that the the hra is running a
deficit for a number of years
before it returns to surplus well we've
had to assume
uh the rent there will be a rent
increase every year
in order to come up with a sustainable
hra business plan anyway
so if we were to not increase rents that
that would mean that the hra business
plan wasn't sustainable
and of course to not agree a rent
increase
for this financial year for 21.22
that has a long-term impact over the
30-year life of the hoa business plan
it has an impact every year because of
that loss of
loss of income so i think that's they
were the factors that cabinet considered
when it came up with its recommendation
for council to increase
only social rents by 1.5 um
and not to increase affordable wins
thank you mr willis um i can't see
anybody else indicating members
um so uh can i ask you to
just note the report please
okay it's a lot of nodding going on so
that that is noted thank you very much
thank you mr willis and thank you mr
porter for your contribution
um agenda item eight
corporate performance report q1 and q2
20 20 21 called upon hannah thorpe to
introduce the item
thank you chairman good evening members
i'm just going to present my screen
and if i could just have an indication
that that's coming across okay
yeah i can see it okay wonderful i shall
work on the basis is working for
everyone and uh crack on and thanks very
much
so um i'm here this evening to give you
an
update on corporate performance for the
current year
i'll be splitting uh this short
presentation in two
so chairman i'll be led by you if you'd
like to pause after we've considered
an update on the current performance
before and take some questions then
before we move on to a brief kind of
proposal for the approach for next year
and i'll be back by you yeah i think we
should because we've got them as two
separate items so if we stop at the end
of the
uh q1 and q2 reports and then you move
on to the
future after that thank you absolutely
yeah that makes good
good sense thank you okay so in terms of
where we are to date um members will be
aware that obviously we were due to do
a refresh on the corporate performance
framework and
including having new measures new
targets
and a whole new approach and that was
due to start this year but unfortunately
um as a result of having to
refocus um the efforts and the workload
of the team
unfortunately that's had to be delayed
and we decided rather than kind of bring
that about mid-year
and we would keep going for this year
with the previous
um performance indicators so we're still
monitoring performance against the
previous corporate plan
and the idea being that we will refresh
this and bring in new measures which
will start for the new financial year on
the 1st of april
um the the kind of the positive of that
means that we've got an opportunity
this evening to have a bit of a
discussion about what that approach will
be
and then to use your feedback and
recommendations to help um
us come up with a hopefully a really
good way positive
forward um so just going back to the
current performance members will
probably be aware as a result of having
to
significantly um change and refocus um
efforts as a result of
the covered pandemic and there has been
an impact on some of our service
provision um in the main we have still
been capturing data
on key performance and in most areas
there's only three
measures in this report where data isn't
up to date and i'll explain that when we
get to
the relevant priority and it's just
worth saying that
where we haven't been coming to you on a
quarterly basis and
reporting um the performance update
and services are still capturing that
data at a local level so
i absolutely need to give you that
assurance that um
that performance is still being
monitored that is something that
managers are still keeping a close eye
on
and we just haven't been um coming to
the meetings to give you an update
um in this capacity um in terms of this
report you'll notice obviously it's
slightly different
than how we did it previously and that
we've only provided commentary
against those measures where we're
outside of performance and
we appreciate that there are the areas
probably the scrutiny members are most
keen
to focus on um so the purpose of kind of
giving a bit of a presentation this
evening is to touch on some of the more
positive areas also
um and in terms of public opinion um
ordinarily we would conduct
a residence survey on an annual basis in
the autumn time
again as a result of my team having to
focus efforts in supporting the covert
pandemic
and we've had to delay that and that
will now be going out and later on this
month
um it still will be going ahead and
we'll still be capturing that feedback
and making sure that we use that to kind
of to focus priorities in the future
and it'll just be happening at a
slightly later date
so in terms of an overview of our
overall position you'll have already
seen this within the reports i won't
repeat that
um in its entirety i think that the
point worth noting
um now is that in terms of the general
state of play
um this time round we've got two more
measures that are
below the target and compared to when we
last presented an update to you
and two measures that have dropped and
no longer green so that's at or
exceeding
our target um i think that context and
given the climate and the kind of the
efforts and the additional work that
is going on um not only on kind of the
covert efforts but also in relation to
eu transition
i think that's we we see that that's
quite a positive
position obviously you would have
expected there to be a slight drop
um as if we've had to kind of redeploy
resources but generally speaking things
aren't looking too unhealthy
so taking each of the priorities in turn
we have six measures that we report on
under clean and welcoming environment
the measures
um within this priority where we're at
our exceeding target around
environmental health requests
um household waste that we send for
recycling is within
target and is still very close to that
target which is
positive and the measure that's below
target is around our miss bing
collection
um now the service director has provided
an update
um to explain the context of that within
the report itself
um the service has been affected
by the need to redeploy resources um to
frontline services at this time
um we know that that's had an effect
we've had to have more use of agency
staff which has affected
um some of the collection rates um and
we know that access issues continue to
be an issue not least as we've got a
vast majority of people now working at
home
also um that said i think it's important
to make the context that we say each
time
um that 99.66 of collections still
successful
um and we do have the positive of having
new vehicles coming
um on stream in early 2021 in the
financial year i should say sorry
um you'll have noticed that i didn't
highlight some of the
other measures and these are the three
um
performance indicators that we haven't
been capturing and that is around liter
detritus and graffiti
um so it's worth making the point that
obviously work in this area has still
continued and that is absolutely a
priority for
us um it's just that the data collection
in terms of whether it's at an
acceptable level
and that hasn't been possible because
the team has had to be redeployed to
focus on other things
um you're probably not overly concerned
because this is a measure of those three
measures of things i know that exercise
members because
they're not the best in terms of the way
that we collate that information
and we're hoping that with the
performance report refresh
this is an opportunity to get far more
kind of reliable and hopefully um
helpful
um data as a result of that what we've
done for the purposes
of this report is just to show them with
a rag status
of where they were on trend for last
time and so litter was
showing as red and then graffiti and
detritus were
green and we were just using projections
to um to say if we had been collecting
it we would have expected it to be
staying at that level i hope that helps
to provide that
context um in terms of supporting
neighborhoods
and we've got six measures that we
capture four of which are exceeding our
target and two which are below i just
wanted to make the point around the
measures where we're
um exceeding target particularly in
relation to homelessness and members
will recall that these were measures
that
um in previous years not too long ago in
fact and where we were quite far outside
of target and thanks to
government intervention funding and
extremely hard work and dedication from
the housing team
and we've seen that improve massively
and it's testament to that team that
despite all of the things that kind of
covert are throwing
at them that that has continued to
maintain
and reach target in terms of the
measures that are below target
anti-social service behave service
requests
are something that have been impacted
again it's worth making the point as
it's
detailed in the report that that team
has been pulled away to
focus on the community hub activity and
making sure that we're contacting our
clinically extremely vulnerable
um people as well so that has had a
direct impact on the ability to
respond to those requests and the the
general service requests um
close to target and in terms of the um
the other
housing measure that's below target um
having spoken to the
um and the landlord manager i understand
that we are still this still very much
enforcement action that's going on
i know that we've served 110 statutory
enforcement notices
um since the beginning of the year which
is still positive
um we were expecting this measure to um
to reduce slightly anyway as our um
rogue landlord program
um ended at the end of march and the
selective licensing scheme is also due
to come to an end so we were
kind of profiling that that activity
would drop off anyway
and obviously again kovid has had an
impact
in terms of promoting inward investment
um here we measure
three um targets um two of which are
green
and one which is red um just to
highlight in relation to the planning
applications the major planning
applications
from speaking with our planning
applications manager and again as
detailed in the report
um the um impact here is on
um legacy planning applications which
are still taking quite a long time
to to resolve and he's got a new member
of the team starting soon so he's really
hopeful that that
performance will improve soon so we're
hoping that that's not nothing to kind
of be overly concerned with
oh actually i was also going to mention
just in relation to
um to this priority although it's just
contextual information
we do obviously within this priority
capture and those that are economically
active
you'll notice at the moment the figure
is dropped slightly and then stabilized
as a result of covered we would be
expecting for that in in future
months probably to reduce so we'll be
keeping an eye on that
and finally statistical information and
it's worth
noting because i probably am going to
steal some thunder different people that
were going to
highlight this um the obvious error for
those of you that have spotted
um is in relation to the number of
starters and levers there was an error
from the report
um we have included in this slide the
correct figure which we had
50 starters and 31 levers so we had a
net increase of 19 and it's not as
stated in the report um that's not that
doesn't quite make sense
so apologies for that um in relation to
this measure we've got five that are on
target
two that are within five percent and two
that are below
um it's worth saying that i
in fact specifically like to highlight
the foi response i know that we're still
only at amber but we're just shy
of the green and actually there's been a
concerted effort to improve this
again members will recall that this has
been a measure that's been kind of quite
below target for some time
and thanks to a completely refreshed
process and
really hard work from the team this is
something that's now clawing its way
back
and doing really well against the target
that's set
um council tax collected is also amber
and that is one that we're going to be
continuing to watch
um uh as i'm sure you're aware again
seems to be kind of a theme of the um
performance report tonight
and covid has obviously had a massive
effect on people's ability to pay
council tax we have seen an increased
level of council tax support um which we
are kind of working hard to support
residents with
this is a measure that we are going to
continue to review we're not we're
only just off the target at this time
but we would expect
and i believe that it is profile to be
slightly under target by year-end
um as a direct result of what's
happening
and in relation to the measures that are
below target sickness days again
it's a measure that's consistently below
target but continues to be moving in the
right direction
and so we're positive that that will
carry on um as projected
and business rates is obviously again
for the same reasons as council tax is
below
the projected target and for this time
of the year
and i believe yep that brings me to a
close in terms of
a summary of um this year's performance
i'm very happy to pause there and to
take any questions
yeah thank you hannah yeah thank you
very much for that
um i do apologize to members as well i
should have announced at the beginning
that i was changing the order so this is
actually a gender item eight but we will
be going back to agendas
lessons five six and seven afterwards so
um
members have anybody got any comments or
queries they'd like to make
no if not i've got a couple um i mean
the first thing is that
uh regarding miss bin collections that
that shows is red
but in my view given the the pandemic
and the old fleet that we've got
a mis collection rate of 0.34 of a
percent is actually quite good
um and i think it feels a bit unfair
that that shown has read and i'm sure
not all members would agree with that
um i noticed that the incidence of
dumped rubbish on council land has gone
up from 134 to 274
so a question is uh is that due to kcc
charging for
certain types of waste that people may
wish to dump
um you've already touched on this hannah
but talked about
action to improve living conditions and
that's very low
and i wondered if maybe bob could
comment on
what the prospects are for that figure
being improved in the future
[Music]
and whilst that's a negative i think
it's very impressive the reductions in
time taken to make homeless decisions
and also the real big reduction in the
number of days in spending hotel
accommodation
um i've got a question on the enterprise
and
employment the numbers of people in
employment count
question is when was that measured and
how soon will we get another figure so
that we can see the full impact of
of covid and the last thing is you've
rightly pointed out hannah
i'd also question the maths but you've
got in first so so there we are
um so i i if we take all the questions
and then perhaps you can
sort of take them off one by one i've
got a question from councillor ropa
i think you need to ask um thank you for
your report
i i have unmuted can you hear me you
come and go a bit
but we can live with that probably right
i'm
i'm having problems with my internet
right um question thank you for
your report hannah first of all uh
question on recycling
is who sets the target is it the
government or is it ourselves
and uh given the sort of current worries
about particularly plastic recycling
um could the target be raised and who
who would do that
thank you okay uh councillor hopkinson i
think you have a question as well
yeah thanks chair um yeah thanks for the
report hannah um
i just was interested in you mention the
delayed survey is going to happen this
month i just wanted if you could tell us
a bit more about it in terms of uh
how many people are going to be asked
how they're selected and what type of
thing you ask them
thank you okay i can't see any more
questions hannah so
if you'd like to run through those oh
well
it's quite a mammoth list
[Music]
at least 20 questions that is very true
and he's actually
greatly missed actually
and i also might bring in colleagues as
well to assist me on this so firstly in
terms of
the misfits and i think it's something
that i say probably at each
performance report update that i give
that the target that we set around that
is highly ambitious
and was deliberately so at that time and
we do believe that
when it comes to reviewing our um
targets for next year that there could
be a better way of compiling this data
one of the things that we're really keen
to see is you're exactly right
actually the collection rate itself is
pretty impressive but if you're one of
the residents that's subject to being
missed then actually you'd be pretty
miffed
and quite rightly so and i think one of
the things that we want to look at is
actually
i think most people can accept if
there's a one-off um misfit and
you know there's always going to be the
nature of the job the case that they
could be in
an occasion when that happens what we
want to understand is using data to see
if we've got consistent issues in
different areas
so what we'll be doing with our kind of
new way of working is trying to use
geographical data to layer that on top
of the performance
to see if we can then target areas as if
we know that there's consistently issues
with access in a particular road
we can do some campaigning around that
and if it's an
issue with people not knowing when to
put their bins out we can target some
education activity around that
and so we want to be able to use
intelligence to kind of
to target that you know in a much better
way um i don't know
mike humber is on the line i didn't know
whether he wanted to jump in at this
point and say anything in relation to
that and also in relation to your
comment around dumped
rubbish as well
hi there yes is that okay i'll come in
there
yeah so on on bins i think uh yeah
hannah is absolutely right um you know
this this year has been particularly
hard
um on the uh on the cruise um
particularly in terms of having to bring
in
agency staff and um you're sort of
maintaining bubbles and it
um you know the crews are out every day
and they work together closely
and um you're compounding
that with bringing an agency staff to
cover um staff who are
shielding ourselves isolating we also
have the issue that uh
you know lots of lots of people are
working from home and
um our large freighters their 26 ton
refuse collection vehicles do have
trouble getting down narrow streets when
there's
cars parked on both sides but despite
all of that you know we're still
managing that that 99.66 percent
uh figure so i think you know i'm
certainly so proud of the
the crew's achievements this year and uh
and managing to
you know keep a a pretty consistent
service um one other thing which is it
is in the notes there but
in order to ease um the number of crew
in the cabs we're collecting food waste
separately and still doing that so that
means
again it's a it's a it's more work so we
have to you know we need more star to be
able to do that
um but it's something that we're doing
you know in the interest of the
the welfare of our of our teams um
in terms of uh dumped rubbish i mean i
mean i think i'll need to go away and um
and get some information on that
particularly from from some enforcement
colleagues
but but i will say that um certainly
we've noticed
that the weight of um
residual waste is up this year is
significantly higher and we think that
that's a you know that's a result of
people being at home
um doing more diy doing more clearing
out the loft those sort of things
um and i think certainly the
you know the fact that uh the hw rc's at
household waste
sites you know we were closed for a
period um
and and you know now they're open
obviously with a bookable service
but i think it's fair to say that um
their
um usage is down and you know and our
residual is up so
there is a you know there's a
sort of comparison to draw there and
certainly i think that yeah
you can also look at um what's what's
going on
in uh yeah out in the environment and
and you know the effect on
the increase on dumped rubbish is is
also linked i think
with you know with all of that
thank you mike thank you i had um
living conditions as the the next point
so um bob do you mind if i bring you in
to
add anything further around that uh
thank you hannah yeah that's absolutely
fine i think the chair
uh asked about um the prospects for the
future in terms of this indicator
that's right and i i think there's a
couple of things to say
first of all we did anticipate that the
numbers would um drop
off during this year and that's partly
because of the
rogue landlord project that was funded
by central government coming to an end
and also elective licensing um and the
selective licensing
ends designation ends on the 19th of
april
um the good there is good news in that
though in that
any property that has a license issued
during the designation period
that license is still valid for the full
five years
so even if we issue a license on the
18th of april
2021 it's valid until the 18th of april
2026
and if any at any point during that five
year period the landlord
fails to meet the requirements of the
license then we can take action
um to either impose fine or prosecute
for that particular property and require
work to be done
so um so yeah so there is a a
a gap in selective licensing but there's
still tools there for us to use to
um to bring around uh prosecutions and
improvements
um the other um the other
key question in this about the future
really is what we do next about
selective licensing
um as officers we've been exploring what
a new designation for selective
licensing might look like
um and um we've got the
the first meeting of the new housing
cabinet advisory group
coming up um later in the week
to look at a work programme and that
work program is proposed to include
a review of the options for the future
of selective licensing
and having we've had early discussions
with the mhclg about the potential for
new selective licensing designations
and they have been supportive and open
to hear our proposals about that so
um so i think there's reason to be
optimistic about
the options for the council to
designate a new selective licensing area
and use that as a tool to see increases
in
in this indicator area in the future
thank you bob hanna back to you
thank you very much the next question
was around and the employment council
this is nomistate
that's provided so it's not um data that
the council holds locally
um i'm not sure on the frequency but i
have asked our expert oh it's quarterly
thank you very much nathaniel
um so that's quarterly data from nomis
and yes it is something that we will
actively be keeping an eye on because we
do expect there to be
an impact as a result of that um
counselor roper's question
in relation to recycling and who sets
the target that's set by ourselves
i mean it's the hardest of either our
previous activity or previous targets
or benchmark data against other
authorities um we
obviously will be using again this
refresh as an opportunity to review that
and one of the desires with this is to
kind of look at a whole
host of other information around that
into people's recycling habits and
be able to kind of you know review which
kind of streams
um seem to be more effective and if
again if there are a way that we can
target kind of campaigns and
communications
to try to improve that and so we're
seeing that this refresh is a good
opportunity to do that
um and then i believe that the final
question was in relation to the
residence survey
and so that is due to go about um the
last week of january so very shortly
we're due to follow exactly the same
methodology as we have in previous years
so we send to a random sample of six
thousand residents
it's random and to an extent however we
do profile it by
um postcode area so that we try to get a
an equal distribution of percentage of
residents that live within each of the
different
areas as far as possible and we
um select those six thousand at random
we send them a postcard they're given an
online
online code which they then must use
to um to register to be able to do that
online
we do give hard copy surveys for anybody
that's not able to access the internet
or
find that a difficult process and we do
support that also
it will be open for a period of three
weeks depending on the take-up
um will depend on whether or not we
issue any kind of reminder
communications
um but take-up has increased year on
year i mean in
the past few years i don't know whether
again because of the pandemic whether
that will
influence people in terms of uh you know
their
desire to complete a council survey or
not i'm not sure but obviously we'll be
doing all we can to try to encourage
that because it is a good
opportunity to benchmark um and we will
broadly be keeping the questions in line
with previous years
um again we had grand aspirations um
last year to do a complete wholesale
refresh around this it's just not the
right time
and i think it will be more helpful just
to get a good indicator of how we're
comparing um year one year to be honest
with you so that's the plan
okay thank you i noticed in the chat um
councillor kane uh is asking what the
general response rate is to the survey
you're putting me on the spot because i
don't have access to the figures but i'm
pretty certain that we hover between 12
between 10 to 12 percent now that
probably sounds really awful in industry
standards that's considered good
um so actually and like i say year upon
year it has gone up and we get
more interaction and engagement so
that's a positive thing
um but obviously we'll be doing all we
can to try to push that even further
okay very happy to share a copy of that
of the questions as well with members i
think that would be really good
fantastic that's really good uh i think
final
uh council on this councillor curry
you've got a question
yeah thank you chair um yeah um hannah i
was wondering um has a public feedback
and inquiries
um increased during the past year and
during lockdowns
and which have been the main areas of
concern
it's a really good question and i wish i
had the answer um
it's worth just kind of capturing
because i'm not sure i made it really
clear the data that we're presenting on
today
is um year to date from april
um up until september so it's kind of
capturing that first part of the year
um i don't have that data to hand but we
it is something that we do monitor and i
would very easily be able to get that
and to share that with you from customer
service's
perspective and i yeah can i either
share that before the next meeting or at
the next meeting whichever is easier
yeah the next meeting will be fine
thanks enough thank you
thank you thank you thank you very much
uh i can't see any other
counselors indicating so um
this is agenda item eight uh can i ask
members to note
uh the comments that have been made and
for officers to
note the comments that we've made thank
you
okay thank you um right
back to the proper order now but hannah
you're still on so gender item five
proposal for new look corporate
performance reporting format okay
lovely thank you and i shall again just
jump back into my presentation
so again working on the presumption that
everybody can see what i'm looking at i
will
go so in terms of our
approach to performance in the future
um i should probably just say um
initially that the purpose of the
that kind of this part of the discussion
is around
sharing the principles and the approach
that we'd like to take
and we haven't been as bold as actually
establishing the measures and kind of
racing ahead with that we thought
actually that you know a better starting
point would be to give you an overview
of where we're at
what our aspirations are what our hopes
are how we plan to deliver on that
check that you're comfortable as a
scrutiny panel that we're heading in the
right direction
and then we'll go away continue to have
meetings with the services
and bring back to a future meeting
albeit before april
um our proposed detailed plan
around performance so i hope that you
know as a starting point is acceptable
to you all
[Music]
in terms of what we're hoping to do
obviously the whole purpose of our
performance
monitoring is to make sure that we're
keeping track against our corporate
statement
so members will be aware that the three
corporate key
objectives for the council are in
relation to growth environment and
communities
so any performance reporting that we do
in the future we'll link
directly back to that to demonstrate to
residents and to demonstrate to you
that we are achieving against our core
objectives
the other thing that we really want to
do is to make sure that we're focusing
on the things that matter most to
residents
i'm not too certain of the 40 indicators
that we present to you this evening
how many of those really mean a lot to
the general public and it's
our kind of passion that we want to make
sure that the information that we give
to residents to make sure it's as
engaging as it can be that it focuses on
the things that we know
matter most and one of the key ways of
doing that will be tying it in
with our the feedback of the resident
survey so we know consistently over the
last
three in fact four years residents tell
us that keeping the streets clean
um they're keeping the streets safe and
that thriving towns are the three areas
that matter most so i think in which
case we need to make sure
that our performance data reflects and
reports on those things
seems to make most sense and we're
really really hopeful
that our new refreshed way of working
will be transparent and it will be
engaging our
um i've got a colleague here nathaniel
who i'll introduce you to in a moment
um we're really sad and we find this
really exciting and we think there's a
lot of opportunity to get people engaged
and fired up
and wanting to to keep track of how
we're doing as a council
so the way in which we propose to do
that is number one
reducing the number of indicators that
we include in the report
now i'm really keen to make sure that
that doesn't mean that that's kind of
less
access and less transparency for people
and in fact what we want to do is
scale back on the number that we present
on but provide
far more context and far better quality
of data that supports each of those
so picking recycling for example rather
than just show you a kind of innocuous
graph that shows a line that kind of
goes like this
um we want to really understand the
information and the data behind that so
we want to understand is it you know
card and paper that is performing really
well are we seeing an increase
in glass and bottles being
recycled is there a reason behind
people's relaxants to
kind of you know get on board with
recycling certain things we want to be
able to give you far more access to
information so you can then interrogate
us
with more confidence in return and the
final thing that we're proposing
to do which is quite scary but we think
it's the right thing
is any of the indicators we want to
report live on our website
so there's far less reliance on bringing
these quarterly reports and people
waiting for data that then by the time
you see it case in point today we're
talking about
data up to september we're now quite out
of date um
our vision with the way that we will
bring this to you in the future
is to make sure that we've got live
up-to-date current information
that can be accessed at any time on our
website
so in terms of what we're going to
continue to measure um
we i mean i'm hoping i get endorsement
from you but as far as we're concerned
this is non-negotiable the things that
we are currently reporting on that we
think we absolutely must
continue to report on all be it maybe in
a slightly different way and with new
targets
um is the list that's in front of you
now so recycling street cleansing
homelessness business rates and council
tax collection
and in terms of the way that we want to
present this
and as i've said we want this to be 24
hours
and available on the website and what
i'm going to do now is i'm going to stop
presenting momentarily and i'm going to
hand you over to
my colleague nathaniel nathaniel fisher
it works in the digital team he's our
business analyst
um i'm sure many of you will have met
him
before and he's just going to talk you
through a concept
and using recycling as an example of the
kind of
level and quality of data that we want
to be able to share on the website
so nathaniel over to you thank you
hannah
um as hannah said we're quite excited
that this is a new way of reporting
making it more accessible more
transparent to residents and councillors
um recycling is an example
that at the moment we kind of drip feed
you with
what the recycling rate is and then you
have to ask questions to get more
details
we want to make it that you can see the
different streams of recycling
under there you can see
how performance is so instead of asking
is it because there's an increase in
waste us
i think mike mentioned earlier that you
can actually see that detail
and don't have to wait for four reports
a year
um which will hopefully have
better questions better recommendations
and a better use of
your time too that we can tackle those
those problems that are important to
residents
um and this one i find quite interesting
that
since covered an increase in plastic and
glass
i don't know if it's because everybody's
drinking a little bit more but
that kind of thing isn't something that
you would see necessarily
on just a recycling rate measure so
we're excited about it and hopefully
there's a bit of excitement from
yourselves as well that this is the way
that we should be presenting
and being more transparent with the data
okay thank you um i just had one
final um slide i won't bother kind of
re-sharing i'll just read that so
what we're after today if possible is to
get approval from scrutiny members on
our proposed approach
um appreciating that this obviously
isn't a finished
package this is very much just the kind
of the direction of travel that we'd
like to go in
we'd like to take this forward with any
recommendations from yourself and that
can either be this evening
um or i'm happy um for members to go
away to kind of mother over
and to email things um over the next
couple of weeks and to nathaniel myself
um we're gonna then and we we've
actually already started to meet with
the different service areas
to agree what we think is an acceptable
indicator
how we propose that we're gonna report
on that and what the target is going to
be and again all of this
we then want to come back and share with
you um our proposal is to come back
to a scrutiny meeting and preferably
before the first of april
and to run through that detail to it you
know to check that you think that that
is
the right way forward and then we can
start implementing that from the start
of the new financial year
and that was it thank you okay thank
you henry nathaniel for for your
presentation um
you know you've touched on it really i
mean i think it's been sprung on members
a bit tonight
so um i don't think we can do any more
than give you sort of
general agreement and encouragement um
you've suggested that members sort of
send you
their thoughts to aid that would you
send
the presentation to all members of the
panel please
so they got them to check on um and yes
i think it's
imperative that we do you do come back
to a meeting before the 1st of april
because it would be good to start from
then if we could
um i can't see any comments from members
um
so are you happy to accept
the proposal with that slides are shared
that you send any ideas and thoughts
that you've got to hannah
and that hannah and nathan you'll come
back to a meeting
well before the first of april with
final proposals for going forward
so i'll move that from the chair does
that find a seconder
[Music]
yeah i'll check in that chair okay thank
you cancer coleman cook
members is that agreed
okay everybody's not in no no no
nobody's shaking their heads so
again once again thank you henry
nathaniel for that and uh thank you
members and we will move on thank you
very much
agenda item six memorials working party
update report
i'll now ask councillor piper to give
the panel an update on the work of the
memorial's working party
council reverend piper over to you
thank you chairman happy new year to
everybody mr chairman we last reported
to you on the 22nd of
our 27th of october since then we've had
a further meeting on the 25th of
november
the details of that are included in the
report
uh that mr charles hungwear's prepared
for us and our
thanks to him as a working party for his
admin support all the way
through this uh our aim just to remind
members is to produce a workable policy
document
for council's consideration and there's
just a couple of comments i'd like to
make
on page three of this report beginning
at paragraph
2.0 it talks about the current situation
and highlights a number of areas of
discussion
that the working party had
we were joined by a guest mr chris
nicholas who contributed
earlier as well um
points uh that particularly were noted
was that we can't change the history
that
that we had but we can educate and learn
for the future
and there is a need to be honest about
our past
in all of these things there were a
couple of recommendations made that we
note that liverpool city council
have made a lot more progress than most
councils in the current uh in the
country
that was correct at the time of
preparing this uh and that we could
perhaps
seek to learn from them i have had a
little bit of a look at what liverpool
council
have been up to um and
you know they've taken a a bold and
courageous step i think in some cases in
some of the things that they've done
but just one example was the naming
of a street sign which was defaced
several times and quite badly and it was
called penny lane
there was some concern that penny lane
was named
after james penny who was a slave trader
and that's where people would go to buy
their
penny slaves um therefore people wanted
it
removed uh the council had a look at it
the museum had a look at it
and in fact they decided that they
couldn't be absolutely certain
that penny lane though it had been there
since
around about that time had anything to
do with mr james penny
uh and they were rather more concerned
with the fact that penny lane
is associated with the beatles in a very
famous song that most of us
well at least some of us anywhere old
enough to remember being released
um so the mayor of liverpool took the
firm decision that it would not be
removed
it would no longer be acceptable to
deface it and so for the moment
penny lane remains as it is
and the museum are going to have a look
at the history that they place around
that particular monument and if i may
chairman there's something that came out
on the 17th
of january of this year from
community secretary robert generic which
has a bearing on what we're trying to do
he has announced changes in the law to
protect public status and monuments
he said people should have the chance to
be consulted
and whether or not any monument should
stand or be removed
and he says uh things that have stood
for generations should be considered
thoughtfully not removed on a whim or at
the behest of a
obeying mob and proper process will now
be required
hence whatever program or policy we
produce as a council
uh into how we do things uh he says any
decisions to remove heritage assets
will require planning permission and
councils will need to do so in
accordance with their constitution
after consultation with the local
community
however he says the secretary of state
will retain the right
of veto power which could be used
to overrule any local decisions
so as a as a working party we're now
looking to our lead officer to produce
the document
which we can then bring back to you but
that's just something
very recent that's come into the mix in
terms of how we consider
how that document will be put together
thank you very much mr chairman
thank you councillor piper thank you for
that and the report that the charles
produced
and for your very up-to-date update very
impressive so thank you
um i can't see any uh comments of
questions members
all right council hopkinson sorry
thanks joe um thanks sir councillor
piper
um i noted um you said in 2.2 whereas
about the sixth bullet point that um
council should consider new and proposed
statues and memorials
um i mean the reason i'm playing this up
is i mean that's great to see
um is basically i have a suggestion for
one and i wonder what if there's a sort
of mechanism for being able to uh
i don't know who should i address that
suggestion to you and now
i haven't cleared cash options i don't
know with the council sorry i'm going to
address that to uh
councillor piper i mean perhaps i can
email you as chair of the committee for
it to be discussed
yes thank you but in brief it would be
um
that before for example uh giving
approval for the george iv
statue to be erected in ramsgate which
is planned for
this year due consideration should be
given
to historical significance the the the
views of
members of the public just in case
people aren't aware
uh ramsgate town council have agreed to
accept the statue
as a gift from the creator
and the team you may or may not be aware
that the
sculptor died very recently so the
statue is being cared for by others
but the town council agreed to look
after it assuming it arrives and is
installed
and so on but if there's a violent
public objection to it then that's
something the council's
uh and certainly uh tdc we will have to
have a look at it but if you want to
email me any particular questions as
chair of that group i'd be very happy to
include them in the discussions for the
next meeting
okay thank you councillor piper i can't
see anybody else
indicating to speak members so can i ask
members to
note the report and thank you councillor
piper you're welcome
lots of nodding going on so the report
is julie noted thank you
moving on to gender item seven tenant
and lease holder services
transition update i call upon bob porter
and sally o'sullivan to introduce the
item
thank you chair uh good evening members
um
thank you for the time on the agenda
this evening
i i want to run through some of the key
um
issues that the report um includes but
before i do that i just wanted to
yeah share with you that uh sally
o'sullivan our tenant and leaseholder
services manager
uh is also in the meeting as is
councillor whitehead he's the cabinet
member for
housing and communities uh and
councillor whitehead has participated in
our
liaison meetings with tenants and
leaseholders and had
uh considerable amount of contact with
tenants and leaseholders
um over the the recent months um since
transition
um the first um the last report that
we presented to you about the service
was on the 27th of august
and five weeks before uh the go live
um dates on the 1st of october
and this is the first opportunity really
we've had to let you know how things
have been going
since the 1st of october we're 15 weeks
into the new service um including
the christmas break um so it's still all
relatively new
um but uh the team have
settled in really well i'm pleased to be
able to say
we've got 58 posts in the new structure
um
and only three um four vacancies in
total
three of those currently covered by
agency staff
and one that we're going to go to
recruitment too soon so
um in terms of recruitment i think we've
done uh really well over that period to
get a full team
of officers together of those 58 posts
28 officers came over from east kent
housing
on a cheapy like transfer from
from ekh to tdc and the remaining posts
are all
new appointments new to the authority
new to the area
we've introduced um new contact
arrangements for the service
new new email contacts um
you may well have seen that in the loop
um
my home at thanet.gov.uk which is
an email address we've shared with every
tenant and leaseholder as a way to
contact us get straight through the team
we've sent out we sent out a newsletter
in the very first week of the service
and that newsletter included a fridge
magnet for everybody
with contact details of how to contact
the service including that email address
and our telephone number and we've also
introduced new generic neighborhood
housing officers which was something
that we really knew tenants and news
holders wanted us to do
have a generic officer that was
responsible for their neighborhood
that could lead on resolving issues for
them
when when they arose and a named person
that they could contact uh and our
newsletters going out to towns and
leaseholders have included the names of
those neighborhood officers
um during that the first 15 weeks or so
we've had
we have dealt with a lot of legacy
issues
that were handed over on transition from
east kent housing but we've had
relatively few
new complaints from tenants and
leaseholders which i think
is uh indicates that the new contact
arrangements for the service
are working well and that people can get
through to the officer they need to
speak to
generally when when they need to
the report itself is in three parts
so we've include we've tried to give you
as much information
as we can about where we are um and
about the scale of the
work that we need to do um to improve
the service and get it to where we want
it to be
so we've included an overall position
statement
on the first two two months
um we've included an update on health
and safety particularly because
health and safety is such a key priority
and i will say a little more about that
in a minute
and we've also included the performance
data for the first two months period
um on the first of october to the end
of november um generally going forward
we'll report
performance um in along with corporate
uh the corporate performance on the same
sort of cycle
and agree through hannah's process what
the key indicators are that you want to
see
uh regularly um but over the first
period while
whilst we're working on improving the
service and embedding it
and we'll try and give you as much
information as we can about where we are
so on health and safety during the first
two month period we've been meeting
regularly with the regulator
for social housing um before transition
that was a process that was being done
jointly with all four councils
but it's now um separated out and we
meet
the regulator as a strict council
representing our new service
and the regulator has agreed our
voluntary undertaking and action plan
for uh tackling issues around
tenant and leaseholder health and safety
that action plan has actions
up until april of this year
and at the at this point i'm pleased to
be able to say that we're
broadly delivering in line with our
action plan and i anticipate to be
at a position in april where we could
say
it's business as usual in relation to
tenant and leaseholder
health and safety we then plan to have
the east kent audit partnership review
review where we are
on health and safety in may reporting
back to the regulator
in june when we hope to be able to say
that they've
removed the regulatory notice on the
council in relation to those issues
in the health and safety report i
thought it might be worth just picking
out a couple of the key things
the first one were is in relation to gas
safety which
was probably the first identified
problem in relation to health and safety
some 18 months ago and i'm very pleased
to be able to say that
the position in relation to gas safety
is very is currently very positive
um at the last um
review of the data we had one property
that
didn't have a current uh gas safety
certificate
and that was the case where the resident
was refusing access to
the engineers to carry out the work um
and we're in the process of
working with other agencies um
to resolve that probably our biggest
concern on transition related to
electrical compliance and you'll see in
the figures
which are quite low we couldn't
transition and we've discussed this with
the regulator
we had very limited confidence in the
data
that came over from esken housing and so
the team have
completed a line-by-line review
of all of the safety certificates in
relation to
electrical safety for both domestic
dwellings and communal areas
and in the report obviously the report
is based on the end of november position
it says we'll complete that work by the
end of december and we did in fact
complete that work by
the end of december um so
and like and since that time the level
of compliance for electrical safety has
increased we expect it to increase
further
over the coming months um
in relation to health and safety um the
we do we are reviewing the position
monthly and we're reporting the position
monthly to the regulator for social
housing and our newly adopted policies
um include formal reporting to members
here and at cabinet on a quarterly basis
i think the second area to highlight is
capital programme
and when we took over the service on the
first of october
the position in relation to the capital
program was very
challenging i think we touched on this
in the earlier report on the budget
we are anticipating a significant amount
of slippage from this year
into next year in relation to the
capital programme
and actually on the first of october
only 13 of this year's allocation had
been spent
um we're working very hard to get uh
projections for the end of the year
uh for the capital program but that has
proved to be quite a difficult
task for a couple of reasons
firstly we've ident we identified quite
a large number of coding errors with
revenue expenditure against capital
codes and capital
expenditures against revenue codes which
the team have been working through
systematically and we also identified a
large number of
late and delayed invoices which we've
also
now checked off and processed through
the system
is some good news on um capital
programme
so although we've got a long way to go
and there's a lot of procurement work to
do
we have had some early success with um
procuring new contracts in a num in a
number of areas so
we're now in contract with them for
external decorations and repairs a
contract that's been desperately needed
for a very long time
and we've also let a contract for the
refurbishment of 14 lifts in our
six tower blocks and a couple of other
blocks as well
um and finally we've uh also let a
contract
for structural and mechanical surveys of
the six
tower blocks and those that survey work
will also include
providing advice about other works that
are needed including
external cladding and helping us with
the procurement
for any works that come out of those
that that piece of work
the performance report itself does
highlight some areas that i would
identify as needing improvement
um satisfaction with repairs probably
the thing that
most impacts um our tenants and
leaseholders
um and we've worked um hard over the car
first couple of months um to improve the
relationships with our key contractors
gas school and mirs
implement new contract management
arrangements
and new ways of improving and monitoring
the service
also void performance and rent
collection i think we also identified as
areas that
particularly need improvement over
the coming months particularly to
support the business plan for the future
to say a little bit about communications
because as well as meeting
our tenant and leasehold of
representatives
we've sent out a number of newsletters
since the
service started so one in the first week
january um and we've sent out um
bespoke uh newsletters to each of the
six tower blocks
um letting tenants there know specific
information about their own tower block
in the most recent newsletter we've
included a survey
about residents priorities for
improvements over the coming 12 to 18
months
and we've already seen a good response
to that survey
we want to use the results of the survey
to help
us put together an improvement plan for
that period
which we will then take through both the
housing cabinet advisory group and also
bring updates here for discussion with
our progress against that
improvement plan so in
in summary what i'd say is i think the
service has made a really good start
um in quite challenging circumstances
both with
um the issues that we uncovered on
transfer but also of course we've had
covered and difficulties with home home
visits and inspections during that
period
the team have settled in really well and
are already showing that they can
resolve
um problems that had previously been
outstanding for some time and
in appendix 4 there's a table there with
some real examples
of some of the problems that we've um
we've
uncovered and tackled and resolved for
people
so that's probably all i want to say
by way of introduction
myself sally o'sullivan and councillor
whitehead are all here
uh if members have any questions okay
uh thank you bob it's very very
comprehensive report
much appreciated and uh you know both
your verbal report and
and the uh the the written report that
we've had
um in fact i can't see any uh members
wishing to raise any questions at the
moment oh yeah councillor boyd just got
a question
thank you and thank you for your report
bob it was just a quick question with
regards to the
capital programme and the miscoding
[Music]
it been subject to how that happened and
also more importantly is there now
um something in place to stop that ever
happening again and moving forward
[Music]
so i didn't quite catch the first part
of that question are you talking about
the time scale and the delay is that the
questions about no
uh so the capital program the miscoding
oh okay yes yeah um uh
well the um i think the re i mean the
reason for that i mean it's easy isn't
it to blame the previous
organization isn't it but um i i think
fundamentally the issues there were
about
a lack of understanding amongst the
officers
um raising those jobs about how the kodi
structure worked
and in particular and i think this is
something that applied across
the way east kent housing previously
delivered services
not having identified lead officers and
clear lines of responsibility
for pieces of work or neighborhoods or
particular contracts and
that is something that we've worked
really hard to make sure
we overcome and every contract
now has a named lead officer contract
administrator
their responsibilities for ensuring um
that
the invoices are coded and the orders
are coded in the right way against
against the coding structure
so i i feel much more confident that um
going forward we won't see those sorts
of miscodings that
we've uncovered okay
thank you bob i can't see any
members indicating so if that's the case
can we note the report members please
yeah everybody's nodding so thank you
very much
moving on gender item 9
review of the osp work program members
are invited to
either comment or simply note the report
i see no comments so can we note that
report please
thank you and finally agenda item 10
forward plan exempt cabinet report list
for period 9th of december 2020 to 31st
of may
unless there's something from the plan a
panel would wish to consider
members are asked to note the report
again everybody's not in and as my
machine is indicating that i've got
just two minutes left the timing
couldn't be better so can i thank
everybody for the participation this
evening anybody that's watching
the live stream thank you